welcome back to CBS this morning Oprah's
unveiling the latest selection for her
book club the new edition is the 80th
book to receive that coveted Oprah seal
of approval first on CBS this morning
years over with her highly anticipated
selection so I've been keeping a secret
for months now and I got to tell you
it's hard to me to keep a secret
especially when I really really really
like something I want everybody to know
it immediately but I have kept this a
secret until now I got an advance copy
of what everybody's calling the book of
the season former first lady Michelle
Obama's new book becoming and I loved it
so much I've already read it twice it's
a tour de force I laughed and I cried it
is exquisitely written it is so
vulnerable so vivid so I want the whole
world to read this book and if you're in
a book club I encourage you to choose
this book for your club and let's all
read it together
it's Michelle Obama's personal story but
I know it will spark you to think about
your own becoming the book is available
starting tomorrow you get yourself a
copy but I believe every woman you know
is gonna want a copy so get one for her
to read it together
you're all gonna love it I also sent
along a clip of my interview with mrs.
Obama so thank you guys you write about
Donald Trump stoking the false notion
that your husband was not born in this
country
on page 353 you say Donald Trump with
his loud and reckless innuendos was
putting my family's safety at risk and
for this I'd never forgive him why was
it important for you to say that at this
time because I don't think he knew what
he was doing that for him it was a game
and for the commander-in-chief which he
now is the threats and security risks
that you face as the commander-in-chief
not even within your home country but
around the world are real and your
children are at risk and the difference
when you when you now in that position
you understand that while while you live
in a bubble your children have to live
outside of the bubble and in order for
my children to have a
normal life even though they had
security they were in the world in a way
that we weren't Oprah's conversation
with Michelle Obama will air in a
prime-time special Thursday on the own
network you can also see it in oh the
Oprah Magazine it's the first time we've
done a big collaboration with all the
Hearst titles are carrying this
interview too
and I'm leaving for Chicago this
afternoon why cuz tomorrow I get to
speak with Michelle Obama you can see
that interview Wednesday right here on
CBS this morning
I read the book over the weekend I have
24 pages of notes that I've now whittled
down to 10 and so I've got to do a lot
of whittling because there's so much in
the book I can't wait for people to read
it oh I can't wait to talk to her about
don't much still to be known you can't
wait to see it exactly right for the
interview
thank you